Today I'm going to talk about word stress and questions versus statements.
In English, statements generally tend to go down in pitch throughout the phrase.
Questions, on the other hand, tend to go up at the end.
For example, "You know what I mean."
This can be a statement if you're talking to somebody and you're explaining something...
...but you know that they understand, maybe because they've had the same experience.
You might say, "You know what I mean."
Statement.
But if you're talking and you wanna make sure that the person is understanding you,...
...you might say, "You know what I mean?"
Asking a question.
Statement: You know what I mean, you know what I mean.
Voice goes down.
Question:  You know what I mean?
You know what I mean?
Voice goes up at the end.
"See you tomorrow."
Let's say you're at work and you know that you're going to be at work tomorrow and so is your colleague.
When you part ways, you might say, "See you tomorrow."
Statement.
But maybe you're not sure that your colleague will be there.
Then you might say, "See you tomorrow?"
Question.
That would be like asking, "Are you going to be in tomorrow?"
See you tomorrow?
Statement: See you tomorrow.
Voice goes down.
Question: See you tomorrow?
Voice goes up at the end.